a tunnel acts like a connection between
two points separated from each other
take these two places for example to go
from one point to the other we need
something that would connect the two and
a smooth transportation is assured by
this tunnel a similar scene is found in
our body as well our mouth or the buccal
cavity to be precise is the place where
the food is masticated that is chewed
the next immediate Junction for
digestion is the stomach and both these
important points are connected via the
single slender tube like structure
called the esophagus can we notice this
pipe here that seam connecting the
buccal cavity and the stomach well
that's the esophagus the other name for
it is the food pipe any idea how the
structure participates in digestion well
you will be surprised to know that this
part of the alimentary canal does not
help in digestion in any way yes this
narrow muscular tract has no role to
play in the digestion process so if not
digestion then what function does it
perform it serves as a passage for the
food this connection between the mouth
and the stomach heads in the
translocation of the food and not its
digestion so does the food from the
mouth travels straight down the line not
really the process is not that straight
and simple
the vaults of the oesophagus contract
and relax alternately allowing the
softball as a food to pasta this
alternate and rhythmic contraction and
relaxation of the muscles
this cult peristalsis this movement has
in propelling the food from the mouth to
the stomach
now the next organ of our interest is
the Stuber what happens when the food
reaches the stomach let's find that out
this stomach is a muscular pouch where
most of the digestion takes place it's
even referred to as the gastric gland we
know that the buccal cavity has
contributed in physical digestion by the
mastication process also the enzymes
from the saliva a gland contribute
partly in the digestion of the
carbohydrates present in the food that
means digestion commences in the mouth
so to keep it a step ahead the stomach
contributes in its own way to the
process it helps in both mechanical and
chemical digestion mechanical digestion
of the food is aided by the churning
process this happens when the muscles in
the wall of the stomach
contract and help in churning the food
within and how does the chemical
digestion occur internally the stomach
has numerous glands present in its wall
which secrete a juice called the gastric
juice it mainly consists of three major
components an acid called hydrochloric
acid mucus and an enzyme by the name
pepsin it takes up the responsibility of
partially breaking down the proteins any
idea what the other two components apart
from the pepsin enzyme are useful for
the hydrochloric acid takes care of two
things firstly it kills all the harmful
bacteria and other microbes that have
entered the system through the food and
secondly it makes sure that the enzyme
pepsin can work properly the breakdown
of proteins partially is not an easy job
for the pepsin hence it requires acidic
conditions given by hydrochloric acid to
work efficiently now tell me one thing
if there is a layer of acid secreted by
the stomach won't the inner lining or
the cells get damaged no the protection
of the inner lining of the stomach is
assured by the mucus layer the mucus
oversees protection of the stomach walls
from the harmful activity of the
hydrochloric acid it makes sure that the
cells remain undamaged so it's the
stomach where the food gets churned
thoroughly and is mixed with the gastric
juice to digest it efficiently now
before moving ahead with the next part
of the alimentary canal there is a small
thing we need to know can you notice
these small structures at the beginning
and at the end of the pouch any idea
what these are these are muscular
junctions that act like gates for
regulating the entry and the exit of the
substances in the stomach yes they known
as sphincters the upper one at the end
of the esophagus is called the cardiac
sphincter it helps in preventing the
backflow of food once it enters the
stomach
similarly the lower one also known as
the pyloric sphincter helps in
controlling the entry of the food from
the stomach in the next part of the
alimentary canal
now that we've learned about the stomach
in details let's discuss the next organ
in the alimentary canal in detail in the
next video
[Music]
you